is in liverpool for us tonight and
shingi uh news then in the last hour of
a second arrest what more do we know
that's right a 33 year old man has been
arrested on the suspicion of the murder
of nine-year-old olivia pratt corbell
that man was arrested also on suspicion
of two counts of attempted murder he was
arrested by armed officers today and an
address on lunsford road in dovecot and
he has now been taken into a police
station for questioning and the police
had made a point of asking people to
come forward and break this wall of
silence and give any information they
have about this incident now in the
space of 24 hours they've made two
arrests earlier today they announced
that they had arrested a 36 year old man
on suspicion of the murder of olivia he
was also arrested on two counts of
attempted murder also that took place in
a similar set of circumstances an armed
raid by officers her in an operation on
thursday evening and we saw police
activity at that address the police put
out a video of a man being led to a
police van from that address in the
heightened area of liverpool but the
police are making the point that they
still need to build a strong evidential
picture around this case they're asking
people to come forward with cctv images
and any information they may have but
they have now made two arrests in just
24 hours